Doktorisa Alti.
Ich bin der Diensthabender in dieser Praxis.
Ich möchte heute mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegelsprachter führen.
Ich werde zunächst Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen
und dann zu Ihren Beschwerden übergehen.
Wenn Sie nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, lassen Sie es bitte mich wissen.
Ich mache eine kurze Pause.
Ich werde eine Kurze machen, um Ihre Fragen zu beantworten.
Sind Sie damit verstanden?
Ja, nur heißt es, lassen Sie es bitte mich wissen.
Lassen Sie es bitte mich wissen.
Ja, lassen Sie es bitte mich wissen.
Wie heißt Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Maria Schell.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Namen langsam ustabieren?
Ja, Martha Anton, Richard Ida Anton, Maria.
Maria Schell, Prof. Schell.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich weiss nicht, was mit mir los ist.
Ich huste seit ungefähr 3 Monaten.
Das will einfach nicht aufhören.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, ich kriege auch nicht richtig Luft.
Okay.
Haben Sie Trockenen-Husten oder haben Sie Ausdruf dabei?
Nein, Ausdruf habe ich nicht dabei.
Es sind Trockenen-Husten.
Trockenen-Husten.
Okay, und die Atemnoten?
Treten die Atemnoten bei Belastung oder in der Ruhe auf?
Die Luftnot ist mehr unter Belastung.
Wenn ich die Treppen steige oder etwas schneller gehe,
merke ich, ich komme so ein bisschen aus der Bruse.
Okay.
Frau Schell, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
56 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann wurden Sie geboren?
Das ist der 10. Mai 1966.
1966.
Darf ich fragen, wie viel wiegen Sie und wie schwarz sind Sie?
1968, glaube ich mich total.
Kein Schül.
1968, nicht 1966.
Okay.
Wie groß unter wie schwarz sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,68 m und wiege momentan 55 kg.
55 kg.
Ja.
Okay, bei Belastung.
So, haben Sie auch Fieber?
Nein, ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass ich heiß bin, Fieber habe.
Also, haben Sie eine Schmerz?
Schmerz, ja, aber ich nicht. Nein, keine Schmerz.
Keine Schmerz.
Und haben Sie Brust angepült oder Brustschmerz?
Oder nicht?
Nein, keine.
Keine Brust angepült.
Okay.
Okay, na husten.
So, Frau Schell, haben Sie Schlafstörung oder wie viel kissen Sie beim Schlafen?
Ich benutze nur einen Kissen, ganz normal.
Beim Schlafen ist es kein Problem, ne?
Sind Ihre Beine angeschwollt oder dikegeworden?
Beine, mit Beinen habe ich keine Probleme.
Keine Probleme.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, Frau Schell?
Wie meinst du das?
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, außer husten und Atemnot?
Nein, nicht, dass ich höchste, momentan nicht.
Nicht.
Okay, so.
Haben Sie wegen der Beschwerden einen Arzt aufgesucht?
Nein, ich habe gedacht, es geht nicht vorbei.
Ich habe gedacht, es wäre ein viraler Infekt,
aber das will und will nicht aufhören.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Frau Schell?
Appetit, Appetit habe ich, ich könnte eigentlich alles essen,
aber irgendwie verliere ich immer mehr Angewicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie im Laufe der Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ich habe abgenommen in den letzten Monaten.
Wie viel Kilogramm?
Das waren bestimmt ungefähr 8 Kilogramm, die ich verloren habe.
8 Kilogramm.
Welche Zeitraum?
Eine Monat?
Ne, so in 3 Monaten ungefähr.
3 Monats.
Haben Sie eine Knuschen oder Schwellung in einem Körperteilen bemerkt?
Im Haus oder Axel oder Leistern?
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Erschöpfung oder Müdigkeit?
Was würden Sie sagen?
Ich bin mit Sicherheit nicht mehr so leistungsfähig wie vor einem halben Jahr.
Ich bin schon immer sehr leicht aus der Puste.
Ich habe gedacht, es wäre nur mit der Luftnot.
Ich merke, ich habe nicht mehr alles so wie früher.
Okay.
Verspür'n Sie Herzrasen oder Schnell- oder Herzschlagen?
Ne, habe ich jetzt nicht drauf geachtet, aber es ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlass?
Ne, kein Problem beim Wasserlass.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Schlafstörern?
Ich habe schon gut eingeführt, damit habe ich kein Problem.
Und Frau Schell, leiden Sie bestimmte chronische Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte, ich meine Bluthochdruck oder so, Kehrkrankheit?
Also bisher war ich nie krank.
Ich bin auch nicht jemand, der gerne zum Arzt geht.
Also ich bereist von keiner Krankheit.
Bisher war ich immer krank gesund.
Okay.
Was haben Sie für eine Medikamente?
Nein, keine Medikamente.
Keine Medikamente.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Frau Schell, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich habe mal geraucht, aber seit fünf Jahren nicht mehr.
Fünf Jahre?
Und davor, wie viel langen haben Sie geraucht?
Wie lange ich geraucht habe, dass du ein bestimmtes, vielleicht 35 Jahre?
35.
Und wie viel haben Sie geraucht pro Tag?
Eine Schachtel oder mehr?
Also viele Jahre habe ich zwei Schatten geraucht,
aber auch zuletzt meistens nur eine oder eine halbe Schatten.
Eine halbe Schatten.
Trücken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol erselten.
Frau Schell, bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Droge oder schon haben Sie probiert?
Ja, vor 40 Jahren als Jugendlicher mal,
aber ich benutze das nicht.
Es hat mir nicht gefallen, probiert und nie wieder in den Mund genommen.
Als Sie jung waren, was haben Sie genannt?
Man hat einen Joint, der raufst.
Okay.
Frau Schell, sind Sie eine bestimmte Medikamente oder Kontrastmittelallergie bekannt?
Ne, ich hatte nie damit etwas zu tun gehabt.
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Eine Allergie.
Okay.
Frau Schell, was machen Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Büroangestellte bei der Stadt.
Angestellte bei der Stadt.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie auch Kinder?
Ja, einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Eine Sohn und eine Tochter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind beide gesund.
Wollen Sie zusammen?
Nein, die sind schon längst aus.
Die haben eigene Familien und leben mit ihren eigenen Familien.
Ich wohne nur mit meinem Mann alleine zu Hause.
Allein?
Und Ihre Eltern, Frau Schell, lebt Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, mein Vater ist bei guter Gesundheit.
Meine Mutter hat Diabetes und Blutdruck.
Aber sonst geht es gut.
Okay.
Frau Schell, ich bin mit meiner Frage fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas Hinsufs oder Fragen?
Hab ich etwas Ernst?
Habt ihr eine ernsthafte Krankheit?
Muss ich mehr Sorgen machen?
Ja, Frau Schell, natürlich.
Ich kann mich fragen.
Frau Schell, ich kann mich fragen.
Ich möchte, dass Sie die Ursache ihrer Beschwerden möglichst schnell wissen.
Aber um die Diagnose zu stellen, sind verschiedene Untersuchungen,
wie körperliche Untersuchungen, Blutuntersuchungen
und blutgeberte Untersuchungen erforderlich.
Wenn Sie körperliche Untersuchungen haben,
dann nehmen Sie eine Blutab.
Dann werden Sie eine Brust-Röntgen-Utersuchung veranlassen.
Dann können wir über Ihre Diagnose sprechen, Frau Schell.
Ja, okay.
Bitte schön.
Ich kann Ihnen nicht sagen, wie die Diagnose lautet,
wie der Name der Krankheit ist.
Ich bin genauso gespannt darauf.
Wir werden gemeinsam uns auf die Suche machen.
Ich bitte um Geduld.
Geben Sie mir Zeit.
Wir werden gemeinsam uns auf die Suche machen.
Wenn Ergebnisse vorliegen, dann werde ich Sie mit Ihnen genauestens durchgehen.
Dass Sie wissen, worum es sich handelt.
Ob das ernsthaft ist oder nicht,
kann ich Ihnen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt leider nicht nennen.
Ich bitte Sie, leider um Geduld.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie Auswürfe?
Das hat der Kollege schon gefragt.
Das ist ein grockener Wurst und kein Auswirk.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Tragen Sie Sport?
Nein, Sport trage ich nicht.
Sind Sie geimpft?
Geimpft gegen was?
Corona oder Tetanus, Hepatitis, für Erwachsenen.
Sind Sie geimpft?
Hepatitis, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Hepatitis wird hier in Deutschland nicht geimpft.
Wenn da nur gegen Hepatitis B,
aber warum sollte ich mich da impfen lassen?
Wüsste ich nicht.
Aber die gängigsten Impfungen in der Kindheit,
das habe ich wohl von meinen Eltern bekommen.
Und gegen Corona habe ich mich impfen lassen.
Danke schön.
Bitte.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie haben Wüsten, bitte sagen Sie mir,
Ihre Wüsten immer da oder kommt es attacken?
Ja, gute Frage.
Das kommt immer wieder unangekündigt.
Ich habe das den ganzen Tag, nicht nur zu bestimmten Situationen.
Vielen Dank.
Bitte.
Im Laufe der Zeit, diese Beschwerden verschlechtern,
die haben sich nicht geimpft.
Der Husn hat zugenommen.
Ich habe auch den Eindruck, ich werde so ein bisschen heiser.
Heiser, ja.
Keine Beschwerden.
Ich habe keine Schluckbeschwerden.
Die haben mich nicht gefragt.
Man könnte fragen, sind Sie mal beim Frauenarzt?
Ja, ich habe keine Schluckbeschwerden.
Man könnte fragen, sind Sie mal beim Frauenarzt gewesen?
Lassen Sie sich regelmäßig untersuchen?
Ja.
Ich war das letzte Mal vor 2 Jahren beim Frauenarzt.
Ihr habt damals gesagt, es ist alles noch.
Unsere Kollegen haben gefragt, nur haben Sie Medikamente oder
Kontrastmitteln aller Jeans.
Wir haben alle komplette Fragen.
Z.B. Tier-Hare-Allergie gibt es,
eine Katze zusammenleben und eine Allergie
Houston gibt es.
Aber Sie haben Allergie oder Verträglichkeiten?
Ich denke, der Kollege hatte Kontrastmitteluntersuchungen.
Ich wollte wissen, ob der Patient oder die Patientin
Kontrastmittel Allergie hat.
Ich weiß, dass er damit umgehen kann.
Aber bei der Anamnese würde ich, wie Sie das geschildert haben,
die Frage stellen, sind bei Ihnen alle irgendwelche Allergien bekannt?
Gegen Medikamente, gegen Nahrungsmittel oder gegen irgendwelche Tierhaare
oder gegen irgendwelche Tiere?
Das ist dann allgemein gehalten.
Was bei Houston v.a. wichtig ist, ich weiß nicht, ob es manchen
so bekannt ist, es gibt die Vogelalter-Lunge,
die Pstakose.
Das ist schon eine gravierende Lungenkrankheit.
Manchmal muss man auch in der Richtung denken oder im Kopf haben.
Das muss nicht immer was Schlimmes sein, was die Leute haben.
Sie können auch mal eine chronische Lungenentzündung entwickeln.
Manchmal haben die irgendwelche Papageien oder irgendwelche Vogel zu Hause,
die sie halt in Kanarien, Vogel oder ähnliches.
Die können manchmal auch Krankheiten haben.
Oder aber auch der Vogelgut kann manchmal in Form von Staub
zu einer Lungenkrankheit führen.
Sowas sollte man auch immer mal hinterfragen.
Haben die Haustiere, welche Haustiere, seit wann,
das sind so Sachen, die man schon fragen sollte.
Nicht nur einfach stochastisch, sagt man, mal das, mal dies,
mal den Umfang.
Wie lebt dieser Mensch, das einfach mal versuchen, herauszufinden?
Herr Hojam, einige Bescheiden hat Kollegen gefragt, oder?
Arztbesuch und Arztbesuch.
Ja, Arztbesuch.
Ich hatte gesagt, ich war nie beim Arzt.
Ich bin kerngesund.
Nein, diese Bescheiden, drei Monate lang.
Deswegen sind die Haustiere oder andere Arztbesuch.
Nee, bisher war ich bei keinem Arzt wegen dem Arztbesuch.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Waren Sie im letzten Jahr aus dem Ausland?
Letzten Jahre, vor einem Jahr war ich im Ausland,
in den Sommerferien.
Wo waren Sie?
Da war ich auf Malta, im Mittelmeer.
Mittelmeer, Malta.
Vielen Dank.
Bitte.
Ich habe auch eine Frage. Leiten Sie unter Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß, was heißt denn Nachtschweiß?
Schützen Sie, vermehrt in Nacht.
Mein Kopf wird nass.
Nicht Ihre, wie heißt das? Ihre T-Shirt, oder?
Meine Kleidung, so viel nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Die zweite Frage ist, trinken Sie vermehrt in der letzten Zeit?
Ob ich vermehrt trinken?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Genauso viel, bevor einem ja auch.
Okay, danke.
Bitte.
Herr Kollege, ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie eine Art Art Art?
Ja, ich kann.
Bitte.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen eine Patientin besprechen,
die ich gerade in Zentralaufnahme aufgenommen habe.
Darf ich die Patientin vorstellen?
Haben Sie es gesagt für mich?
Ja, ja, klar.
Darf ich eine Einwand hier aufhören?
Sie haben ganz am Anfang gesagt, Sie sind der dienzarmene Arzt
in der Praxis.
Jetzt sind Sie plötzlich der Arzt in der zentralen Notaufnahme.
Da müssen Sie aufpassen, wie Sie sich vorstellen.
Das geht dann nicht.
Eine Notaufnahme ist keine Praxis.
Da müssen Sie sagen, der dienzarmene Arzt hier in der zentralen Notaufnahme.
Okay.
Ja?
Ja.
Gut.
Es geht um Maria Schinal.
Elf, Rath, Elf.
Carl Maria Schell.
Schell.
Okay.
Sechs, 50 Jahre alt.
8, 1 Meter, 8, 6, groß und 5, 5 kg schwer.
Frau Schall befand sich um, seit Punktes gesprochen, normal, normal allegemane Zustand
und war vollständig orientiert.
Vollständig orientiert.
Orientiert.
Ja.
Frau Schnell.
Schnell.
Ich stelle sich bei uns wegen seit drei Monaten, drei Monaten,
und belästungabhängige Atemnot vor.
Die Patienten berichtete, als Begleitzentrum,
berichtete die Patienten über dysphonie und trockenen Husten,
die auf Fragen nach Beinödem, Beinödem, Fieber, Sputung oder Brustschmerzen
und die vegetative Anamnese ergab,
gewitferlust 8 kg innerhalb von drei Monaten.
Drei Monaten.
Und so, sie habe keine chronische Erkrankungen.
Sie wurde bis hier keine Operiert und Ernehmene,
keine regelmäßig Medikament.
Sie nehmen keine regelmäßigen Medikamente.
Sie nehmen oder man sagt, sie nehmen regelmäßig keine Medikamente.
Keine Medikamente, ja.
Sie sei ex-Rocherin seit fünf Jahren.
Davor, sie habe fünf, drei, sechs Jahre lang
zwei oder ein halbe Schachtel pro Tag geraucht.
Sie trinken selten Alkohol.
Sie haben mit Jugend ein Joint probiert.
Mit Drogen oder in Kontakt, hat sie aber nie regelmäßig konsumiert.
Sie haben keine Allergie.
Und in Familien Anamnese befinden sich Diabetes Melutus
und Arterialpertonie beim Mutter.
Und Vater sei gesund.
Sie sei verheiratet und sie habe eine Sohn.
und eine Tochter, sie arbeitet als Büroamtarin in Stadt, beamt Stadt und sie wohnt allein aufgrund
der Symptome der Patienten, sie wohnt allein zu Hause, sie lebt mit ihrem Mann zu Hause, die Kinder sind nicht da,
aber sie lebt mit ihrem Mann zu Hause.
Okay, und der Symptome der Patienten gehe ich von Verdacht viral Pnomonie aus und differenzial diagnostisch
kommen COPD, Tuberkloser, Lungenkarst, Sinon, in Betracht.
Wie kommen Sie auf eine Viralpnomonie oder Lungeninktionen?
Sie haben Trockenenpusten und sie haben keine Fäber und auch sie leitet an dysphonie.
Deswegen komme ich auf Viralpnomonie, aber sie haben Gewicht, 8 kg.
Das ist das eine, das zweite ist, dauert eine Viralpnomonie so lange?
Ja, 3 Monate.
3 Monate ist zu lang für eine virale Infektion.
Ich meine, ein banaler, grippaler Infekt mit dem Influencer Viren, das ist auch ein Virus,
das dauert keine 3 Monate, das ist im All vielleicht ein paar Wochen, aber dann hat der Körper das Immunsystem,
die Viren eliminiert und dann hat man das hinter sich.
Dass das ein virale Infekt ist, glaube ich nicht, so Sonderformen kann es natürlich sein,
aber ich würde nicht die virale Form in den Vordergrund stellen.
Da müssen Sie aufpassen, müssen Sie dann auch ein bisschen logischer denken, nicht einfach nur erwähnen,
weil sonst kann es sein, dass der Prüfer das dann aufnimmt und sagt,
jetzt muss ich aber hinterfragen und dann verheddern Sie sich, kommt ein Problem nach dem anderen
und dann finden Sie sich nicht mehr zurecht.
Sagen Sie etwas, was auch nachvollziehbar ist, was auch verständlich ist, was man auch begründen kann,
sonst kriegen Sie Probleme.
Ja.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie einige Differenzialdiagnosen erwähnt.
Was machen wir denn jetzt mit der Patientin?
Ja.
Haben Sie sie dann mal untersucht?
Ja, ja, so erst werde ich Kapallei untersuchen, durchführen.
Das müssen Sie schon gemacht haben, wenn Sie dem Oberarzt das ganze ja übergeben
oder Arzt zur Arztgespräch führen, dann müssen Sie die Patienten ja schon untersucht haben.
Ja, dann müssen Sie auch darüber berichten, dass Sie dann sagen, die Anämnese gab das und das
und bei der körperlichen Untersuchung zum Beispiel auskultiert oder aber auch verkultiert
oder aber abgedrückt oder getastet, was haben Sie festgestellt?
Darüber müssen Sie jetzt berichten.
Ja.
Bei der lunge Askultation erwarte ich Rassel-Fain, Blase, Rassel-Gerausch.
Und dann Klop-Schall, Klop-Schall, Lokal-Frimitus,
und dann machen wir das doch mal gemeinsam.
Wir hören die Patientin jetzt mal gemeinsam ab.
Vor 10, 15 Jahren war es hier in Deutschland auch in manchen Kliniken so üblich,
dass wenn irgendein Arzt einen etwas pathologischen Befund beim Patienten mal gehört hat
oder festgestellt hat, dann hat man die neuen Kollegen, die sich in der Ausbildung befand,
immer dazugerufen und gesagt, hör mal hin und sag mir mal, was du da gehört hast.
Und da muss man diese Begriffe, diese Untersuchungen auch langsam beherrschen,
dass man die dann auch benennen kann.
Bei dieser Frau, die hat geraucht, die wird eine Raucher-Lunge haben.
Vielleicht eine beginnende COPD, die sie nicht hat.
Wie macht sich eine COPD bemerkbar?
Es ist ein verschärftes Atemgeräusch.
Es muss keine grobblasigen oder feinblasigen Rassel-Geräusche ergeben.
Aber das, was Sie hören, ist ein verschärftes Atemgeräusch.
Wenn die Luft da reinjagt, dann zischt es.
Sie hören, dass das nicht sehr leicht flexibel ist, sondern das sind starre Wände
und die Luft pfeift dann dadurch.
Also verschärftes Atemgeräusch.
Und wenn Sie dann herkutieren, dann ist das eine etwas überblähte Lunge.
COPD-Lah haben eine Überblähung der Lunge,
weil durch diese obstruktive Störung kommt zwar viel Luft rein,
aber es geht nicht alles raus.
Aber in der Zeit wird die Lunge einfach größer.
Und dann ist da viel Luft, so als wenn Sie auf eine Trommel hauen.
Das nennt man dann Hypersonora-Clobschalk.
Hypersonora-Clobschalk, ja.
Ja, Hypersonora.
Nur, dass man dann diese Begriffe dann auch dementsprechend logisch mitteilen kann.
Dass Sie dann sagen, ja, dann müssen Sie auch sagen, wo.
Ist das in den Basalenabschnitten, ist das überall, ist das apikal oder wo.
Das ist einfach ubiquitär, nicht überall gleich.
Oder die Fußhypersonora-Clobschalk, verschärftes Atemgeräusch auf beiden Lungen.
Damit haben Sie den Befund komplett wiedergegeben.
Ja? Ja.
Gut.
Und was machen wir noch?
Der Mensch ist ja in die Notaufnahme gekommen, oder die Frau.
Nur einfach Untersuchung und dabei belassen geht nichts.
Sie haben sich das Blut abgenommen, Sie haben dich halt auch ein EKG geschrieben.
Weil jeder Patient, der in den Notaufnahmen kommt, muss ein EKG geschrieben bekommen.
Ja?
Eine Notaufnahme ohne EKG, vor allem internistische Patienten geht nicht.
Das ist ein Muss.
Ja?
EKG angucken.
Blut abnehmen.
Was interessiert Sie denn am meisten bei der Blutentnahme?
Ja.
Was war das letzte Normal?
Blutgall Gas Analyse BGA.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und dann, ja.
Das sind eigentlich schon die wichtigsten Sachen.
Aber wenn man Blut abnimmt, kann man das nicht.
Bei uns gab es mal so eine Abkürzung.
HKE.
Das hieß dann H-Crea-Elyte.
HKE, H-Crea-Elyte.
Also Natriumkalium, H-Creatinien.
Und das sind so die wichtigsten Parameter, die man braucht.
Leberwerte braucht man nicht sofort.
Aber was ist noch wichtig?
CRP ist wichtig.
Und ich brauche noch ein Blutbild.
Ob jetzt groß oder klein, das sei mal dahingestellt.
Ich möchte wissen, wie hoch die Leukozytten sind.
Warum?
Weil Sie wollen ja wissen, ob dieser Mensch eine Infektion hat.
So, jetzt haben Sie gesehen, CRP ist nicht der Wille.
Ja, Leukozytten sind auch nicht der Wille.
Und was wollen Sie noch wissen?
Worauf gucken Sie noch als Zweites?
Ja, äh, ich habe das ja auch gesagt.
Ja, äh,
Bayders Blutgasanalyse,
Sauerstoffwerte und
Kohlendioxidwerte,
Zum Ausstellersens, CRPD.
Ja, ja, da würde ich, das fühle ich aber nicht in der Notaufnahme direkt machen.
Ja, wenn jemand mit einer Belastungsdüsbne kommt,
dann reicht erstmal nur eine Sauerstoffsetigung aus.
Saturation, einfach nur einen Finger klip,
gucken, wie hoch ist die Sättigung?
Eine Blutgasanalyse können Sie nicht in allen Notaufnahmen machen
und nicht alle Kliniken bieten das.
Ja, wenn Sie in einem ganz kleinen Krankenhaus sind,
können Sie nicht immer eine Blutgasanalyse durchführen.
Das ist nicht möglich.
Aber jeder Monitor hat ein Sättigungsgerät.
Ja, dass Sie dann einfach gucken, wie hoch ist denn die Sättigung?
Warum ist das wichtig?
Warum ist die Sättigung wichtig?
Ja, äh, ich, ich möchte CRPD und Asthma
äh, so, äh, aus, auszuschließen, auszuschließen, ja.
Ja, sehr gut, aber Sie möchten erst mal wissen,
wie hoch die Sättigungen sind.
Ja, nicht gleich mit Krankheiten denken,
sondern erst mal nur klinisch denken, ja.
Wie hoch, wie viel Sauerstoffsättigung hat denn dieser Mensch?
Ist es 96, 97, ist das 90 oder ist es vielleicht drunter,
unter 90?
Weil warum?
Wenn das unter 90 ist, wenn das bei 90, 91 ist,
dann müssen Sie diesen Menschen sofort Sauerstoff geben.
Ja, richtig.
Ja, und mit einer Blutgasanalyse
machen Sie nur eine weiterführende Diagnostik.
Da sehen Sie, ob der eine respiratorische
oder eine restriktive Problematik hat
oder mehr eine respiratorische Problematik hat oder nicht.
Aber das wollen wir jetzt erst mal gar nicht wissen.
Ich will erst mal nur wissen, wie hoch ist die Sättigung?
Das reicht einfach nur mit einem Messgerät, ja.
Also, Sie haben die Sättigung gemessen,
Sie haben in EKG geschrieben und EKG ist völlig blande.
Also, Erz können wir einfach in Ruhe lassen,
das ist nicht das Problem.
Ja.
Und als nächstes, was machen wir dann?
Ja, wir können Aufnahme,
Aufnahme verlassen,
zum, eine,
die Patientin ist Ex-Rocherin, deswegen,
es könnte sein, eine Tumor
oder
ja, die Patientin hat keine Angehung,
Schuhe, Leinbäine, aber es kann sein,
eine Herzinfuzions,
Red Herzinfuzions,
wegen der COPD.
Das kann alles möglich sein.
Wir wollen einmal gucken,
ob man da hinweise,
man muss vorsichtig formulieren, nicht gleich nach Krebsgucken
und nicht gleich nach Herzinfuzionsgucken,
sondern Sie sagen, ich mache eine Röntgenübersichtsaufnahme,
damit ich sehe, ob da auffällige Befunde zu sehen sind
oder nicht.
Ja.
Und dann könnte sein, dass der Prüfer fragt,
was kann denn da auffallen?
Dann, er sollten Sie erwähnen,
dass es eine Neoclasie sein,
das kann ein Lungenkrebs sein,
das kann auch eine bakterielle Infektion sein,
zum Beispiel,
obakulose,
oder es kann auch eine andere infektiöse Erkrankung sein,
hatte ich vorhin erwähnt,
zum Beispiel Vogelhalter, Lunge
oder andere Sachen
oder strukturelle Herzkrankheiten
oder Lungenkrankheiten,
die miteinander kombiniert sein können.
Das sehen Sie dann auch,
einfach nur vorsichtig formulieren.
Ja.
Jetzt haben Sie die Röntgenübersichtsaufnahme gemacht
und der Radiologe ruft sie an
oder schreibt in seinen Befund,
er sieht einen kleinen Pleurererguss rechts
und zentral scheint da
eine tumorverdächtige Struktur zu sein.
Ja, er sagt nicht Lungenkrebs,
er sagt nicht Lungenkazinom,
er sagt auch nicht, das ist ein Lymphknoten,
sondern er schreibt einfach
eine tumorverdächtige Struktur rechts zentral.
Ja.
Gut.
Jetzt haben wir schon mal die wichtigste Information herausgefunden.
So.
Und was machen wir dann?
Ja.
Wenn eine unkläre Befunde hindröntgen,
werde ich Torax-Tomografie durchführen.
Was für eine Tomografie?
Macht man eine Kernspuntomografie
oder was anderes?
Komputer-Tomografie.
Computer-Tomografie, CT, ne?
Gut.
Machen Sie nur von der Lunge
oder wenn Sie schon mal dabei sind,
machen Sie auch vom Bau?
Torax.
Ja, ich würde Torax-Tomografie durchführen.
Also, wenn im Röntgen der Verdacht
auf ein Tumor besteht,
dann würde ich in Abdomen-CT gleich mitfahren.
Sonst muss der Patient hin und her gefahren werden.
Dann macht man beides auf einmal.
Neure Geräte machen mit weniger Strahlenbelastung.
Das geht ratzfatz.
Und dann haben Sie auch gleich ein Staging gemacht.
Wenn der Verdacht im Röntgen auf dem Tumor besteht,
dann denken Sie mal ganz schnell und sagen,
ich brauche Informationen.
Ist da ein Tumor in der Lunge?
Und wenn da der Tumor drin ist,
ist da auch was im Bauchauern,
Leber oder Nebenniere
oder aber Knochen, Wirbelsäule,
ja oder nein.
Dann haben Sie gleich alles mitabbeklärt.
Jetzt machen Sie die Computertomografie.
Die Computertomografie sagt,
ja, da ist ein zentral großer Tumor,
ungefähr 5 cm groß.
Man sieht im Mediastinum
vergrößerte Lymphknoten
und auch kontralateral-bilehr
vergrößerte Lymphknoten.
Darüber hinaus sieht man
verdächtige Lesionen in der Leber
und eine vergrößerte Nebenniere links.
Ja, dann
wir sollen eine
pathologische
Biopsy
und Entfernung
oder eine Lymphknoten
entfernen,
um damit
histologische
Untersuchung
zu führen.
Erfolgen kann, ja, sehr gut.
Aber
wenn Sie sagen Lymphknoten entfernen,
ist das ja eine Operation.
Manchmal kommt man aber auch
sehr leicht an diese Histologie dran.
Wie kann man das machen
und das muss eigentlich immer gemacht werden?
Wenn jemand egal, ob Tumor da oder nein,
seit längerem eine Heiserkeit hat
oder einen Hustenreiz hat,
was müssen Sie mit so einem Menschen auf jeden Fall machen?
Das ist vielleicht eine internistische Frage,
aber immer eine Bronchioskopie machen.
Ja.
Und heutzutage
kann man eine
Bronchial-Ultraschall kombinieren.
Haben Sie den Begriff Ebus schon mal gehört?
Ebus.
Ebus ist ein
endobronchialer
Ultraschall.
Ja.
Und mit diesem endobronchialen
Ultraschall,
kann man auch gleich eine Probeentnahme machen.
Und zwar werden die Lymphknoten meistens punktiert
und die nennt man dann eine T-B-N-A-
trans-bronchialer
Lymphknotenbübsi.
Ja.
Und das ist mittlerweile zwingend notwendig.
Wenn man den Verdacht auf einen Lungenkarzinom hat,
bevor man irgendwelche Operationen macht,
irgendwelche Lymphknoten entfernt oder
wo die Sache herangeht,
die Bronchioskopie mit dem Ebus und der T-B-N-A
ist die einfachste Methode,
wie man ganz schnell an eine Probe kommt.
Es gibt aber hin und wieder mal Fälle,
wo der Pneumonologe leider nicht erfolgreich ist.
Weil T-B-N-A bedeutet,
sie sind blind, sie nehmen den Schallkopf
und orientieren sich danach und dann gehen sie mit einer Nadel durch
die Wand des Bronchios hindurch.
Und wenn jemand atmet, kann der Lymphknoten hoch und runter gehen.
Den können sie treffen oder nicht treffen.
Wenn die Bronchioskopie unauffällig ist,
dann kommt erst ihre Methode mit der CT
gesteuerten Probeentnahme in Frage.
Da würde ich aber nicht direkt in die Lunge punktieren,
sondern da sucht man sich entweder die Nebenniere
oder aber ganz einfach wäre es in der Leber.
Probeentnahme brauchen wir. Also das ist wichtig.
Die Reihenfolge muss man sich immer merken.
Röntgen, Schnittbildgebung, Probeentnahme.
Und die Histologie sagt mir, womit ich es zu tun habe.
Und dann haben sie den Namen für die Krankheit gefunden.
Und dann müssen sie das Staging
oder das Stadium festlegen,
wie weit ist die Krankheit ausgeprägt,
wie weit ist die Vertragung?
Wie weit ist die Krankheit ausgeprägt,
wie weit ist die verteilt und erst davon abhängig,
stellen Sie dann ein Therapiekonzept zusammen.
Ja, also, was muss man aber bei dieser Patientin sagen?
Die Informationen hatte ich Ihnen ja gegeben.
Das sind kontralaterale Lymphknoten
und es gibt metastasenverdächtige Lesionen in der Leber
und auch in der Nebenniere.
Und damit ist es eine,
metastasierte Erkrankung
und das ist eine palliative Situation.
Ja.
Und jetzt müssen Sie nur gucken, was es ist.
Ja, Sie haben den Verdacht.
Es ist Lungenkarzinom.
Aber Lungenkarzinome werden wie aufgeteilt?
Welche zwei Gruppen?
Ja, nach der Histologie
die Schmerz und die non-Smalzkarzinome.
Vor allem in Deutschland sagt man kleinzellig
oder nicht kleinzellig?
Kleinzell oder non-Kleinzellig?
Nicht kleinzellig, nicht non-Kleinzellig.
Non gibt es im Deutschen nicht.
Kleinzelliges Karzinom
und keinzelliges Lungenkarzinom.
Nicht kleinzellig.
Wenn man die englischen Begriffe wählen will,
kann man sagen Small cell lung cancer
oder wenn man sagt non-Small cell lung cancer,
NSCLC oder SCLC.
Die muss man schon so kennen.
Jetzt haben Sie die Probeentnahme mit der TBNA gemacht
und der Pathologe sagt, er sieht Formationen in der Probe,
die für ein nicht kleinzelliges Lungenkarzinom
vom Typ der ADENO-Karzinome richten.
Ja.
Jetzt haben Sie die wichtigste Information damit herausgefunden.
Was denken Sie dann?
Sind wir dann fertig?
Was macht das?
Die Patientin ist Stadion 4.
Lungen-ADENO-Karzinom.
Ich würde sagen,
eine palliative Therapie
behandeln.
Ja, sehr gut.
Das wäre jetzt zu viel.
Aber wenn Sie diese Informationen in der Prüfung erwähnen könnten,
könnte das Prüfpunkt ergeben.
Beim nicht kleinzelligen Lungenkarzinom
ist mittlerweile Standard, das man dann sagt,
abhängig von der molekularen Untersuchung.
Die Molekularpathologie spielt eine sehr, sehr klare
Rolle mittlerweile.
Der Begriff ADENO-Karzinom reicht bei Weitem nicht mehr aus.
Es gibt bestimmte Targets oder Punkte
oder Treibamutationen auf der DNA dieser Krebszellen,
die eine gezielte Therapie oder molekuläre
Target Therapie möglich machen.
Und sämtliche Experten, egal ob jetzt die Europäische
unkologische Gemeinschaft, die ESMO oder die deutsche
unkologische Gesellschaft, die DGHO, beide sagen,
keine Therapie ohne Molekularpathologie.
Warum?
Weil die zielgerichteten Therapien,
wenn da eine Mutation nachweisbar ist,
viel, viel besser werden können.
Als eine klassische palliative Chemotherapie.
Ja?
Und dann müssen Sie in der Prüfung dann sagen,
so viel ich weiß,
muss aktuell oder heutzutage zunächst eine molekulare
Untersuchung des TUMOS erfolgen
oder eine Genanalyse,
damit man dann die geeignete Therapie festlegen kann.
Welche Therapie,
das müssen Sie nicht wissen.
Wenn das irgendjemand fragt, dann ist er böswillig.
Das kann nur eine unkologe wissen.
Ja?
Ja.
Okay?
Gut.
Soweit verstanden?
Ja.
Aber eine Sache würde ich aber auf jeden Fall noch machen.
Das wäre noch eine Skelett-Synthik-Kaffe.
Ja.
Und, ja,
und was man noch mal machen kann,
ist eine Kernspintomographie vom Kopf.
Ja?
Das ist jetzt zwar kein kleinselliges Lungenkarzinom,
das muss dann eine Kernspintomographie erfolgen.
Warum?
Weil der Kleinzeller sehr häufig ins Gehirn geht.
Aber,
und aus Erfahrung weiß ich auch,
das Adeno-Karzinom geht doch häufig ins Gehirn.
Und dann sollte man auch eine Kernspintomographie erfolgen.
Zum Beispiel,
um das Gehirn zu erfolgen.
Und dann sollte man auch eine Kernspintomographie vom Kopf
auf jeden Fall noch machen.
Zur Kompletierung des Stages.
Ja?
Noch Fragen?
Oder war das ein bisschen zu speziell?
Ich denke,
bei der FSB können wir sagen,
eine Full OP,
eine Neu-Ajuant-Chematerapie
und Radioterapie empfehlen.
Und dann?
Ja.
Das kann man so nicht sagen.
Es gibt mittlerweile wieder ein ganz anderer Standard.
Mittlerweile sind auch Checkpoint-Inhibitorien
für Neu-Ajuante-Therapien zugelassen.
Und heutzutage bestrahlt man die Patienten
nicht vor einer Operation.
Wenn, dann werden sie adjuvant bestrahlt.
Aber Neu-Ajuvant bestrahlen tut man nicht mehr.
Mittlerweile gibt es sogar die Empfehlung,
dass die Neu-Ajuante-Ajuante-Therapie
eine kombinierte Chemoimmuntherapie,
also Chemosubstanzen mit Checkpoint-Inhibitorien,
kombinieren zum Downstaging, sagt man.
Das heißt, den Tumor soweit es geht,
verkleinern, operieren
und dann noch ein paar Monate adjuvant die Therapie fortführen.
Ja?
Und vor zwei Monaten ist jetzt eine Kombination zugelassen worden.
Man hat darunter auch sehr hohe pathologische Remissionen gesehen.
Das bedeutet, dass unter dieser Neu-Ajuante-Therapie
gar kein Krebs mehr im Tumor mehr nachweisbar war.
Also ein Y-Petinol, sagt man dazu.
Und das bedeutet, dass die Therapien sehr, sehr wirksam sind
und dass die Überlebensraten für diese Patienten deutlich länger sind.
Ja?
Aber das sind sehr, sehr spezifische Informationen.
Ich habe speziell jetzt ein Stadium IV gewählt,
damit man nicht in diese Detailwissen hineinkommen.
Beim Stadium IV ist wichtig, dass man erwähnt,
die Molekularpathologie ist auf jeden Fall notwendig.
Wenn die Molekularpathologie nicht gemacht ist,
dann sollte man keine Therapie beginnen.
Das ist falsch, das ist nicht richtig.
Neue Therapien-Affärbung, Ko-Chan?
Ja.
Also die neuesten Therapien, wie gesagt, es gibt so einige Tage,
man guckt zum Beispiel nach der ALK-Mutation oder Translokation
oder ROS1-Mutation, oder man guckt nach der EGFR-Mutation,
man guckt nach der Karas-Mutation,
BRF wird angeguckt, oder N-Track 1 bis 3 wird gemacht
und man guckt sich den PDL1-Status an, inwieweit,
wie hoch der ist, ob man alleine Checkpoint-Inhibitorin geben kann
oder nicht und davon abhängig wird dann eben die Therapie dann festgelegt.
Aber Leute, die sich damit auskennen, wissen,
wo man das dann auch sehr leicht ablesen kann.
Die Gesellschaften haben gute Seiten aufgebaut.
Wenn man weiß, wie man damit umzugehen hat,
macht man einfach im Internet die Seite auf und guckt,
ah, das, das, das, liegt das vor, dann diese Therapie,
und wenn das nicht liegt, dann ist diese Therapie zu wählen.
Also man muss einfach nur den Weg können.